Welcome back.
We are on problem number 10.
I'm trying to do as many
problems as possible, because
today is Thanksgiving.
And I want to build up an
appetite to really take down
that turkey.
Anyway, they say, what is the
coordinate of the point on a
number line that is exactly
halfway between the points
with coordinates 53 and 62?
So the point that's halfway
between those two is just
going to be the average
of these two points.
So what's the average?
It's 53 plus 62 over 2.
And that's what?
5 plus 6 is 111,
so it's 115/2.
That equals 57.5.
So that's the answer.
And this is one of those ones
we have to fill it in.
57.5 is half way between
the two.
And at first, I was
little taken aback
because of the decimal.
I was thinking maybe is an
integer number line.
But they don't say that.
So on a regular number line,
you can have decimals.
So this is the point
that is exactly
halfway between the two.
This is the coordinate
of the point.
Number 11.
A certain triangle has
two angles that
have the same measure.
If the lengths of the two sides
of the triangle are 50
and 30, what is the least
possible value for the
perimeter of the triangle?
All right, so we've
got a triangle.
And we know that two
of these sides are
the same angle, right?
And we know, from geometry, if
the two base angles are the
same, then that means that these
two sides are going to
be the same.
And they tell us that two of
the sides are 50 and 30.
So either this could be 50
and this could be 30.
Or this could be 30 and
this could be 50.
Because this can't
be 50 and 30.
These have to be
the same thing.
So we want to know the
least possible
value of the perimeter.
So if we want the smallest
possible value for the
perimeter, we want
more 30 sides and
less 50 sides, right?
So why don't we make
this side 30?
Because then, this side
will be 30, and this
side will be 50.
And the other option would
have been to do this.
50, 50, and 30.
But clearly, this would have
had a larger perimeter,
because we would have
used 50 twice
instead of using 30 twice.
So this has a smaller
perimeter.
And what is the perimeter?
It's 60 plus 50.
It's 110.
That is the smallest perimeter
we could have.
Next problem.
Problem number 12.
I don't want to use
the whiteboard.
There's something psychological
about a
blackboard, I think.
It makes it more engaging.
All right, if x squared minus y
squared is equal to 77, and
x plus y is equal to 11,
what is the value of x?
So this is something that some
people-- oh my God, I've got a
system soon. of equations.
Or I've got a quadratic.
What is it?
All you have to do
is factor this.
What is x squared
minus y squared?
Well, a squared minus b
squared is, a plus b
times a minus b.
Or, in this case, x squared
minus y squared, that's just x
plus y times x minus
y is equal to 77.
And the biggest clue on why you
can do that immediately,
is that they told you what
x plus y is, right?
So we know that x
plus y is 11.
So 11 times x minus
y is equal to 77.
So now we know, divide
both sides by 11.
x minus why is equal
to 7, right?
Now, we have a very
straightforward system of equations.
And we want to solve
for x, right?
So we can let the
y's cancel out.
Let's take that top one down
here and just rewrite it.
x plus y is equal to 11.
Add the two equations.
x plus x is 2x.
Minus y plus y is 0.
y is equal to 18, right?
7 plus 11 is 18.
2x is equal to 18.
x is equal to 9 Done.
Next problem.
OK, we are on problem
number 13.
Tamara cut a circular pizza into
wedge shaped pieces, one
of which is shown above.
The tip of each piece is at
the center of the pizza.
And the angle of the tip is
always greater than 20
degrees, but less
than 30 degrees.
OK, what is one possible value
for the number of pieces into
which the pizza is cut?
OK, so this is interesting.
So we have a pizza pie, although
it could just be a
regular pie.
And each of her slices
goes to the center.
And this angle right here--
so let's call it theta.
It's going to be-- it's greater
than 20 degrees.
And it's less than 30
degrees, right?
Well, let me ask a question.
If theta was 20 degrees,
how many slices
could she have cut?
Well, there's 360 degrees
in a circle, right?
So if every slice is 20
degrees-- Well, 20 goes into
360 how many times?
20 goes into 360,
18 times, right?
2 into 36 goes 18 times.
So if every slice is 20 degrees,
it'd be 18 slices.
Similarly, if every slice was
30 degrees-- 30 degrees goes
into 360, how many times?
Well, it goes into it 12 times.
12 slices.
you
So we know that the slices
are larger than 20 and
less than 30, right?
So the slices are going
to be greater than 12
and less than 18.
And so you, literally,
can pick any number.
The answer could be 13, 14,
15, 16, or 17 slices.
Any of those numbers would be
a suitably correct answer.
That sometimes confuses
people, but
you should be confident.
Any of these numbers that
you put down will work.
Maybe you want to put the
middle one just to be
comfortable.
I think that would be
a 25 degree slice.
Next problem.
14.
We have this sequence a,
3a, dot, dot, dot.
[SNEEZES]
The first term in the
sequence above is a.
I just went for a hike at a
place called Windy Hill, and
it was freezing.
The first term in the sequence
above is a, and each term
after the first is 3 times
the preceding term.
If the sum of the first five
terms, is 605, what is the
value of a?
So the first five terms-- well,
that's just going to be
a, 3a, and then the next
one's going to be 9a.
The next one is going
to be 27a.
to be 81a, right?
That's the first five terms.
So you add them all up.
3 plus 9 is 12.
This is where I always
mess up.
3 plus 9 is 12.
12 plus 27 is 39.
39 plus 81-- 9 plus 1 is 10.
And then 1 plus 3 is 120.
So that equals 120a.
So these are the first
five terms, right?
Each one is 3 times
the preceding one.
And the sum of these
is equal to 605.
What is the value of a?
a is equal to 605/120.
And let's see, can
we simplify this?
Sure, if we divide the top and
the bottom by five, how many
times does 5 goes into 120?
It goes into it 24 times.
Are these divisible by 3?
No.
I think that's in simplest
terms, because you can't
divide by 2.
Can't divide by 3.
121 times 5 is 605.
So I think that is the simplest
form that you can do
this problem.
I'm running out of time.
So I will wait to
do next the next
problem in the next video.
See